was getting D's and F's and the world
was telling me I was a loser my teachers
were telling me a loser my friend's
parents weren't saying to my face that I
was a loser but I could see it in their
eye that I didn't think I'd be
successful because the game I played
unlike today's game in the 80s early 90s
was school was the way out going to
Harvard was the great accomplishment not
being a successful entrepreneur was a
different landscape and so the why was
to stick to everybody like I used to sit
there as a 13 14 15 16 year old and look
at my class and my teachers I'm like I'm
going to show all of you you think I
suck I'm gonna be the biggest best
person on Earth
Gary take one mark
[Music]